sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen in frau
bundeskanzlerin es war der 29 oktober da
habe ich an dieser stelle gefordert es
braucht eine langfristige perspektive
damals ging es darum dass die
infektionszahlen stiegen und schon
damals wäre es notwendig gewesen
transparent durchschaubar zu machen wo
wir hin steuern wie wir reagieren und
wem wir wann helfen damit es
zuverlässigkeit damit es vertrauen gibt
das könnte man ja sagen kann er das
gesuchte vertrauen in die
bundesregierung irgendwie egal sein ist
es mir aber nicht warum weil mit weniger
vertrauen erleben wir eben auch dass die
maßnahmen weniger ernst genommen werden
und das ist das problem vor dem wir
heute stehen
und jetzt kann man moment lang lachen
über diese sache mit den friseuren und
ich gönne jedem und jeder hier und
anderswo eine frisur aber könne auch
übrigens den friseurinnen die einnahmen
aber damit ist nichts anderes getan als
dass man das gefühl hat hier soll dem
volk ein bisschen gegeben werden das ist
aber keine strategie
das ist nicht lang bis sich das ist
nicht klar das ist nicht eindeutig und
deswegen sage ich haben wir weiter ein
riesiges problem und ich will eindeutig
sagen für mich heißen perspektiven
stufen pläne nicht dass wir jetzt öffnen
wir alle wissen doch dass die mutanten
sich längst ausgebreitet haben und
weiter ausbreiten werden in deutschland
es geht nicht um öffnen jetzt sondern es
geht darum dass wir allen klarmachen in
unserem land woraufhin wir gemeinsam
arbeiten und dieses woraufhin wir
gemeinsam arbeiten bei weiterhin jetzt
vorsicht das haben sie gestern nicht
geliefert und wenn das nicht
funktioniert wenn es nicht funktioniert
in der mpk und wenn die autorität eben
nicht reicht dann meine damen und herren
sage ich hier in diesem haus dann müssen
wir
es tun von hier aus in diesem parlament
beschließen im bundesrat beschließen
dann haben wir eine transparente
eindeutige gemeinsame haltung die
diskutiert ist die transparent ist die
von alternativen lebt meine damen und
herren und das wäre notwendiger denn je
es ist doch ganz klar die wir sind
gewählt als abgeordnete und die menschen
haben uns vertrauen gegeben dass wir
diese dinge auch tatsächlich lösen und
regeln und deswegen ruft sie auf meine
kolleginnen und kollegen ausdrücklich
von union und spd sehr in ihren
fraktionen ganz offensichtlich habe es
in der von der cdu fraktion ja auch
lesen können sehr viel ärger gehabt sehr
viel ärger mit der bundesregierung
und es ist eine auseinandersetzung die
es auch ganz normal da will ich mich
auch gar nicht darüber erheben und es
werden fehler gemacht und diese fehler
muss man thematisieren ich glaube es ist
total richtig aber es reicht doch nicht
hinter verschlossenen türen weil was
durch gestochen wird darüber zu reden
sondern das muss genau hier passieren
damit wir es in zukunft gemeinsam besser
machen meine dann und das wissen das
betrifft auch umso mehr die
wirtschaftshilfe 100 tage waren die
menschen ohne hilfe und ohne einen cent
einnahmen auf dem konto 100 tage und es
tut mir leid ich kann jetzt heute nicht
halt du ja rufen weil wir es endlich mal
das programm aufgelegt wird 100 tage
ohne hilfe und die hilfe die kommt ist
ja auch noch längst nicht ausreichend
sie bedeutet für viele solo
selbstständige für künstlerinnen und
künstler eben weiter dass sie nicht
existieren können von dem was sie
eigentlich brauchen und deswegen sage
ich meine damen und herren diese
wirtschaftshilfen dass es ein riesiges
versagen der bundesregierung ein hin-
und herschieben zwischen
wirtschaftsminister und finanzminister
ich verstehe auch nicht warum die spd
weiterhin nicht beim unternehmerlohn
mitmacht geben sie sich einen ruck und
helfen sie den menschen wirklich das hat
auch mit vertrauen zu tun
das hat auch damit zu tun wie wir aus
der krise wieder rauskommen meine damen
und herren
und dann wir haben monate gebraucht bis
es eine regelung zum home office gab und
mir macht es sorgen dass wir einerseits
darüber reden wie schaffen wir es denn
mit den kindern ich konnte leicht dazu
aber immer noch sind heute 20 prozent
mehr menschen auf den weg zur arbeit und
nicht im home office als im märz
warum ist das so weil sie sorge haben
dass sie in ihrem unternehmen gedisst
werden in ihrem unternehmen womöglich
entlassen werden weil sie nicht
mitmachen und deswegen ist es auch eine
politische frage ob ihr klar und
eindeutig sagen home office muss jetzt
gemacht werden auch damit kinder in die
schule und die kitas geöffnet werden
können man gedanken gestellt ich will
genau genau dazu etwas sagen nach einem
jahr pandemie können wir nicht mehr
sagen schule auf oder schule zu und ich
verstehe nicht warum man sich darauf
nicht einigen konnte gestern ich
verstehe vor allen dingen nicht warum es
nicht gemeinsame voraussetzungen dafür
gibt dass an schulen und kitas
sicherheit herrscht für die kinder und
für die erzieherin und für die lehrerin
der brinkhaus
die erste voraussetzung wir müssen jetzt
ja gemeinsam schaffen dass es für
wirklich für alle schnelltests gibt dass
es wirklich ein luftfilter programm gibt
was auch ankommt weil wir werden wir
davon ausgehen können dass das irgendwie
dann alles doch im april vorbei ist aber
das andere da bin ich ja sehr bei ihnen
wo ist denn das große programm mit einem
fonds mit einem bundesfonds was dafür
sorgt dass wir jetzt herausfinden welche
kinder brauchen besonders viel hilfe wo
ist denn das wo ist denn das programm wo
wir dafür sorgen dass wir tatsächlich
feststellen welche kinder brauchen
besondere hilfe die wir zum teil ein
jahr nicht gesehen haben die war nicht
in der not betreuung die bahn würde
und deswegen sage ich ihnen ganz
eindeutiger brinkhaus bitte lassen sie
uns das zusammen machen ohne sich
gegenseitig an zu meckern
das haben die kinder in diesem land
überhaupt nicht verdient was haben die
kinder in diesem land nicht verdient
ganz im gegenteil was was müssen wir
eigentlich tun
wir müssen doch jetzt sagen konzepte für
die schulen sind da so dass man sich ja
dort arbeiten kann und dort wo es in der
schule nicht geht und wo auch der
wechsel unterricht noch nicht reicht
dann lassen sie das was an fantasie
schon längst da ist in lüneburg wird in
der kirche unterrichtet und in
wachenroth hinter rot einem kleinen ort
eine türen spanischen grenze wird im
gemeindehaus unterrichtet weil die leute
sagen wir können das mit sicherheit hin
bekommen und deswegen bevor man sich
auch die friseure einig dann bitte mit
aller kraft dafür sorgen dass schule
sicher für schülerinnen und schüler für
eltern und kita erzieherin auch
tatsächlich stattfinden kann meine damen
und herren
diese anstrengungen davon hängt sehr
viel ab
und ich finde es ja sehr bemerkenswert
frau bundeskanzlerin dass sie auch
öffentlich gesagt haben ich konnte mich
da nicht durchsetzen
wo sie sich aber hätten durchsetzen
können das ist bei der bereitstellung
der voraussetzung das finde ich nach wie
vor den zentralen punkt dazu gehört
übrigens auch dass wir sehr direkte
hilfe brauchen
viele dieser kinder leiden jetzt am
meisten an der pandemie aber womöglich
eben auch am längsten nämlich dann wenn
sie schon längst vorbei ist und deswegen
brauchen sie jetzt auch unmittelbare
hilfe
also von mir aus den studenten der den
flüchtlingskindern hilft und die dann
hinterher trotzdem noch sagen können ich
will ingenieurin werden oder ärzte oder
die großmutter die im feuerwehrhaus
erklärt wie das mit dem kegeln und mit
den klaren ist ja warum denn eigentlich
nicht wir könnten sehr viel mehr wenn
wir mit sehr viel mehr fantasie
unterwegs wären und die künstlerinnen
und künstler würden am ende sogar noch
im museum oder in der galerie dafür
sorgen dass kinder nicht einfach zu
hause sitzen gelassen werden vom
sitzenbleiben zu
beziehungsweise der fall schon meine
damen und herren
diese pandemie wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen ja und gleichzeitig sollten
wir uns jetzt mit der frage
auseinandersetzen was kommt eigentlich
danach was kommt eigentlich danach nur
dann werden wir es auch wirklich
schaffen dass hierdurch zu halten also
nach dem lock down und dem lockdown wann
kommt eigentlich open ab das klingt ein
bisschen nach aufbruch das klingt für
manche sogar ein bisschen nachtanzen und
lassen sie uns gemeinsam auch in diesem
aufbruch arbeiten
wir sehen in der beschränkung was uns
was bedeutet begegnung nähe kontakt
kinokultur clubs wir sehen was machbar
ist wenn gemeinsam gehandelt wird ja das
sehen wir tatsächlich wenn sich alle
gemeinsam anstrengen
wir sehen was möglich wäre und wir haben
nicht nur diese eine krise die
klimakrise steht weiter nicht und die
arten krise die stillste von allen eben
auch nicht und wenn wir bei dir einen
sehr viel geduld brauchen
es ist bei den beiden anderen so dass
wir sehr viel und sehr schnell handeln
müssen und meine damen und herren auch
dass auch das von diesem ort aus diese
20er jahre könnten solche 20er jahre
werden wenn wir zeigen dass wir krisen
tatsächlich gemeinsam bewältigen mit
allem was uns zur verfügung steht mit
aller kraft und immer mit den menschen
gemeinsam und zwar von hier aus nicht
top down sondern von hier aus mit
demokratischer beteiligung und
vielleicht können wir dann irgendwann
gemeinsam darauf tanzen
vielen dank
[Applaus]